comment maintenir du lien social en
pleine période de confinement grâce à la
visioconférence
aujourd'hui nos ordinateurs nos
téléphones et même nos télévisions en
sont équipés impossible de passer à côté
la caméra intégrée et partout en 1994
rien de tout cela mais un visiophone et
c'était une révolution technologique
pour les coques ordinateurs téléphones
ordinateurs télévisions marier les deux
et vous obtenez un visiophone une mini
caméra pour que votre interlocuteur
puisse vous voir et un petit micro pour
la voix après le visiophone arrive la
webcam à la fin des années 90 les
particuliers l'adoptent et y voit une
nouvelle façon de communiquer ben ça
fait drôle parce que tu vois tes parents
et c'est pas comme tu les lois en
réalité pratique pour garder contact
la webcam entraîne parfois quelques
frustrations bon c'est vrai quelques
fois on en aura envie de se faire hacker
lave plus blanc que on se fait des
bisous on se rapproche de l'écran on se
fait des signes
grimaces bon pour compenser un petit peu
quoi la majorité des utilisateurs s'en
servent pour communiquer avec leurs
proches
d'autres préfèrent s'exposer au monde
entier à l'image des influenceurs
d'aujourd'hui en 2007 fannie ce qu'il
met chaque soir devant des milliers
d'internautes est une fenêtre ouverte
dans la maison tout simplement on est
certainement exhibitionniste en tout cas
dans la dent dans la limite de ce que je
considère l'acceptable c'est-à-dire
l'environnement de cette pièce et la
caméra ne se balade jamais ailleurs
aujourd'hui en plein confinement face à
la solitude les français multiplient les
actes vidéo sur skype our house party
par exemple l'application whatsapp a été
téléchargée plus de 465 points en france
bien que la première semaine confinement
[Musique]